what is up guys today in this video I'll
be showing you my top 5 favorite magic
training methods that you can get profit
while doing by no means are these the
best options these are just my top 5 my
favorite ones that I like to do and keep
in mind that these are not in order this
is just 5 training methods so let's get
into the video
I get those goosebumps every time I need
time go down to this aisle I can those
comes every so the first method is
enchanting jewelry and right here you
need 27 magic and some cosmic runes and
some emerald rings and we are making
them into rings of dueling and I have
the timer in the right side and so
you'll see how long it takes to make
them
[Music]
all right I am done so now it took a
minute so now I will go ahead and sell
them all in the grant exchange and
instant sell them okay they did an
instant sell but I will be back when
they sell okay they have sold it took a
few seconds but so it took one minute to
do this we got 925 XP in one minute
so it says 22.8 k experience of 23k
magic experience and we bought them for
this
so I actually bought 27 of them but I
only bought 26 cosmic runes because I
met messed up on that so we're going to
do the 740 that it costs to buy the
Rings times 26 so 19 to 4 so we'll write
that down here and then we will add the
cosmic runes 117 times 26 302 for so
then we will do the 25 seven-four-zero
that we made - the 302 for from the
cosmic runes - the 19 - for zero and
then wheel times this by 60 because it
took 1 minute so you can make 208 K and
get 23,000 experience per hour a quick
correction on this because this actually
goes down so it's actually 925
experience per minute so 925 times 60 so
55 k experience you can expect to get
that if you're a hundred percent
efficient we're going to go ahead and
assume to 100% efficient so you can get
50,000 imagining experience doing this
and make 200 K very nice now you'll do
with sapphire rings all you need to do
this is cosmic runes any water staff
because you need water runes and then
you need level 7 magic to enchant
sapphire jewelry
you
so stop the time 50 seconds and now we
will sell all the ring of recoils so
again we spent 302 for on the 16 1 5 7
plus the 302 for from the cosmic earn so
we will do the 23k 842 - these 16 1 5 7
- the 302 4 times 68 so 279 but it
actually took 50 seconds from around
that to 300k so you can make 300k and
then you can also make let's do the 1 3
8 0 - 9 - 5 because that's what it says
right here and we have 95 from before so
what times that by 60 so about 30k magic
experience and 300 k GP very nice as
well now the second method that I
recommend for this one you need a smoke
Donald staff because you need fire in
air rooms you need soft clay however
much you want to use and however many
law runes that you have compared to soft
clay so you need to have the same amount
you also need to bring some coins you
also need to have 40 construction to
build the study and then you also need
25 magic to make Barak teleports which
is what we're going to use so go ahead
and teleport to your house make sure you
have a butler hired and then run to the
study actually might need to get my
Butler there's an option on here to
column 2 you column over here so what
you do you call them and you have them
go to the bank you use this on them
and then you want to do that yes and
type into
five or however many you want to do so
then go ahead and go your study and now
you'll start the timer and then go ahead
and make all of your rock teleports
[Music]
and then when you need more go ahead and
talk to your Butler he will give you
more I'm going to make one more because
I only made one more lon rune I'm I only
brought one more so then make it and
then teleport back and we will sell them
so now we are at the bank and I went
ahead and did the math on what it cost
for 25 long rooms and 25 soft clay and
it was 9275 so let's sell these so 13
what was it 13 825 made from the brach
teleports - the 9275 equals four
thousand five for 4550 so I guess and
then we will times that by it took a
minute about so we'll do a minute
because those 22 seconds is messed up
because I was trying to get the audio to
work so times up by 60 so 270 K minimum
doing this method and then also 875 XP
so 875 times 60 so you'll get 50 2500
experience as well and also if you want
an in-depth guide on this method I've
made a video I will leave it in the
description if you need to see that
another one of my favorite magic
training methods that makes you profit
is alkyne so in order to do this you
want to go ahead and by nature room and
figure out what the prices of it so it's
207 so you want to buy items that you
can make money on by making over 207 on
them
so right now ruin plate legs I can show
you on OS buddy room plate legs so it
shows that they al 438 400 so if I buy
them for 38 K I am making a hundred I'm
making 200 TP per thing so I bought 70
of them you can also do this with room
plate skirts as a sell for 38 K and then
another favorite item is room to HS as a
cell for 38 K as well I'll put some
items on screen now that show you that I
like to do the most that'll make you
profit
and then I will go ahead and buy nine
more of these 69 one of these so I can
do this and then I will help them and
make sure you have a fire stuff on and
set it up so it's right here and if you
can't do it go into your settings and
make it so you can out higher items and
now I will start a timer and I will see
how long it takes and how much money we
make
[Music]
don't
okay so we have finished so two three
minutes and forty seconds how much magic
experience that we get we got
seventy-three thousand point nine K per
hour and I guess that's about 75 K I
messed up a few times and now I will do
the math okay so I wrote down the
numbers of what it cost
so the 38,400 that we made per plate
body on each out or times that by
seventy to get how much we made and then
we will minus our two six seven four
four nine zero from what we spent so
thirteen thousand five hundred and ten
and we know times that by seventeen
because of the three and a half minutes
that it took sixty divided by three and
a half is 17.1 so we made 230 k along
with some great experience 75 k
experience very nice so now we will do
barrows because this is actually my
favorite message to do it because you
can make loads of money doing this and
you slowly get magic experience if you
just keep doing it over and over I've
done a bunch of videos on this so I
highly recommend you watch them because
you can make anywhere from like during
the K now or if you don't get anything
all the way to like over 1 millon hour
that's not counting supplies but I'm
probably gonna speed this up like a lot
or just skip to the end so you guys can
see it so I'll be back when I'm done
with this run
[Music]
alright I'm opening the chest okay it
took exactly five minutes that's
actually a pretty good time for me so
now it will teleport to clan wars and do
some math so now time for some math so
again we made 27 6 to 6 times 12 because
60 divided by five minutes so 330 K and
then additionally we made 1110 XP 1110
times 12 so you'll get about 13 k ex
perience with also 330k an hour and if
you get a Barrow's item you can get much
more money per hour I've done a lot of
videos on barrows so I have some hours
in there because I've done 200 chests
and 100 chest so the money is more than
that but this is a good way to get money
and get some metric experience slowly
but surely and again this is not
counting supplies so it's a little bit
less than that number but you still make
a lot depending on the chest you get the
fifth and final method is bursting dust
devils all you need for this is 65
slayer 70 magic and you need to be on
the ancient spell book this is my friend
THC butter doing it from a video that I
made before so I will leave this in the
description because it's a very good
training method to make money and get
magic experience so as you can see he
has 43 prayer which is another
requirement he has his prayer pots he
has darts to trap them and then he has
his room pouch with water runes death
runes and chaos runes each and I need a
rune pouch so you can bring one so you
run back and forth after hitting them
with the darts and then you stack them
and trap them and then you burst them
and he did it for an hour so I will see
you at the end of the hour and then he
will sell all the items and we will see
how much you make so he will quickly
sell everything that he got
you
so he made a total of seven
three K and we did the math and minus
the supplies he made one hundred forty
two thousand two hundred twenty four GP
in an hour and he had one hundred and
twelve thousand magic experience that is
insane thanks for watching guys I hope
you guys give this video a like it took
me a long time to make and edit I'm
sorry that it was so long but I wanted
to put all the information in that I
could again these methods are in no
particular order and if you do not agree
with my methods that is okay you can go
ahead and leave your favorite methods in
the comment section if you guys have any
suggestions for any new videos go ahead
and leave it in the comments section or
if you just want to say something I'll
make sure to reply make sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can see
all my new content and thanks for
watching guys stay tuned for the next
video